They're Jewish see my mother hold there do I see my father?
Oh, they're do they call to me. Oh they're do they call to me oh?
They're do they call to me
That Bo's a little big for you isn't it my mother made me said I'd go into it
Find your way home
You are free
We're taking your asses to the highest peak in the realms ashes it was our last wish
Well must we go
To a realm beyond your own
There's only one peso can get you and you need to go
They call me Mamiya smartest man alive
First you need to cut off my head wait what?
Thanks you get
You got a handle or special I?
Know you're a god not of this room, but there's no mistaking it
He doesn't know does he about your true nature or his own
The longer you wait the more damage you do he will resent you and you may lose him forever
There are consequences to killing a guard
Power of this weapon any weapon
comes from here
Would only win tempered by this?
is
The self control of the one who wields it
Where are your health?
This is no ordinary illness the boy is true nature your true nature fights within him
So amina
like you know
We are not met we
Are more than that?
The responsibility is far greater
Can you kill something that big
You